ja er hier hinter mir der Jagd in diesen
Minuten auf die USA zu auf die Westküste
auf Florida das sind Live Bilder von Ian
ein Monster Hurricane ein
wahnsinnswirbelsturm so einen hat es in
dieser Region seit einem Jahrhundert
nicht mehr gegeben und mittendrin ist
eine deutsche Urlauberin aus München
eigentlich wollte Yvonne nur Urlaub
machen das Elternhaus besuchen jetzt
steckt die gebürtige Münchnerin
mittendrin im Monster Hurricane er ist
lebensbedrohlich hat verheerende
Auswirkungen ihren
ich war am Anfang eigentlich eher wird
schon nicht so schlimm werden aber
draußen ist es heftig der See steigt wie
gesagt es wird eine flugquelle erwartet
von drei Metern und so langsam wird es
mir auch mulmig muss ich sagen und so
sieht er aus das ist das Auge des
Wirbelsturms von oben aus dem Weltall im
Durchmesser ist dieses Monster bereits
1000 km groß und diese Bilder zeigen die
Brutalität dieses Hurricanes
Windgeschwindigkeiten von mehr als 215
Stundenkilometer unzählige Blitze
drumherum jeden Augenblick trifft der
monstersturm südlich der Tampa Bay und
nördlich von Cape Coral aufs Land direkt
bei Yvonne und auch bei den Wendlers
Michael Wendler und seine Laura wohnen
direkt in Cape Coral wie sich die beiden
vorbereiten unklar das letzte Foto von
Laura ist bereits schon eine Woche her
Angst um die Wendlers bei Yvonne wohl
eher
die 58-Jährige sorgt sich um das Haus
ihrer Eltern die nächste Stunde wenn wir
hier im Haus bleiben und zur barrikieren
hoffen dass die die Fenster
den Land halten weil wie gesagt also
hier in diesem Fenster die masterbettung
auch
keine Storm shutters haben und das
Wasser steigt zunehmend also man sieht
es so ein bisschen wie das hier hoch
kommt Meter hohe Wellen werden erwartet
eine lebensbedrohliche Sturmflut auch
für Yvonne in enables sitzt sie fest im
Haus ihrer Eltern
der Kühlschrank ist gefüllt die
Badewanne voll damit im Notfall die
Wasserversorgung sichergestellt ist in
der Garage hat sie extra Scharniere
angebracht die im Notfall stabilisieren
soll so einen Hurricane hat es seit 100
Jahren nicht mehr gegeben und rast jeden
Augenblick mit ungeahntem Ausmaß über
Yvonne über die
ja mit Yvonne waldbrunnen versuchen wir
jetzt zu sprechen sofern der Strom noch
nicht ausgefallen ist Frau waldbrunnen
ich sehe sie auf jeden Fall ich hoffe
sie hören mich auch herzlich willkommen
und sagen Sie uns doch bitte wo befinden
sie sich gerade genau und wie erleben
sie auch die Situation
also momentan bin ich in Naples das ist
ungefähr auf Höhe vom Auge des Hurrikans
die Situation hat sich ziemlich
zugespitzt also es fing an heute Nacht
gegen zwei jetzt ist es ziemlich heftig
mit Windgeschwindigkeiten und Böhlen
teilweise bis 200 Stundenkilometer das
heißt Palmblätter fliegen rum die
Straßen sind nicht mehr passierbar es
wurde mandatory Eva creation angeordnet
das heißt also die ganzen Platz Sounds
müssen die Häuser verlassen und den
Schalter gehen und es wird eine
Flutwelle erwartet die bis zu drei
Metern hoch ist uns aus dem Haus ich
weiß nicht ob man sieht im Hintergrund
da ist eigentlich ein kleiner See der
ist bedenklich angestiegen die Screens
also das ist der Mückenschutz hier hat
es schon rausgerissen und es peitscht
immer wieder und ich hoffe einfach nur
dass die die Fenster durchhalten
und sonst haben wir uns mehr oder
weniger für barrikadiert hier mit Wasser
mit viel Eis im Kühlschrank also Eis zum
Gefrieren weil man eben nicht weiß wie
lange der Strom dann vorbeikommen wird
wir sehen im Hintergrund die eben
beschriebenen wir sehen durch die
Fenster natürlich auch dieses Gitter
dieses dieses Mückennetz was da so hin
und her fliegt
wenn jetzt wirklich so eine Welle kommt
so eine Art Flut dann bezweifle ich
jetzt auch wenn ich nicht gerade bei
ihnen stehe dass das irgendwie hält also
sie sehen nicht so aus wie
verbarrikadiert warum gehen sie denn
nicht auch in einer dieser dieser
shelter
ja gut dieses shelters ist ein bisschen
gewöhnungsbedürftig da ist also wirklich
ganz Naples mit Hund Katze Maus und
wer kann bleibt natürlich in den Häusern
wir haben eins das zum Glück aus Stein
gebaut ist also da dürfte nicht so viel
passieren wir haben auch hier das sieht
man jetzt leider nicht auf der anderen
Seite die Hurrikan shutters unten
nur dieses Fenster ist leider nicht
geschützt aber eigentlich ist es immer
besser hier zu bleiben wenn was wäre das
nächste Hurricane Shelter ist jetzt
nicht so weit weg wir haben alle
Batterien aufgeladen wir haben es mit
Wasser versorgt also wie gesagt die
meisten die nicht müssen bleiben in den
Häusern also ich bewundere ihre Ruhe
ehrlich gesagt ich hätte wahrscheinlich
meine Beine in die Hand genommen und wer
angefangen zu laufen oder zu flüchten
kam das für sie nicht in Frage noch aus
dem Ort irgendwie rauszukommen oder ist
das gar nicht mehr möglich
es ist momentan nicht mehr möglich also
man darf eigentlich nicht mehr auf die
Straße es gibt noch ein paar sind noch
die ganzen Brücken gesperrt die
Interstates gesperrt oder ist es
blockiert auch durch Wasser und es kam
eigentlich gar nicht in Frage für uns
also wir wurden noch lustigerweise bei
der Ankunft in Miami gefragt ob wir
wirklich nach Naples fahren wollen von
dem Immigration Officer aber das ist so
schlimm wird ehrlich gesagt hat ich
jetzt auch nicht erwartet was
prognostizieren denn die Behörden vor
Ort
die sagen dass es jetzt in den nächsten
acht Stunden müsste das Ganze durch sein
das Auge trifft jetzt glaube ich in den
Minuten oben bei Captiva Island also ein
bisschen nördlich von Fort Myers sind
hier so ich würde mal sagen 50 Meilen
auf Land und ähm ja sie sagen euch alle
hohe clean up together das heißt wir
helfen alle zusammen es wird alles nicht
mehr so sein wie es war und das sieht
man auch z.B auf sanibal Island Captiva
Island das ist eine weil das ja diese
muschelinsel und da ist es so dass alles
also tatsächlich bis zu dem Briefkästen
die ja so ungefähr bei mir so diese Höhe
Brusthöhe sind alles schon unter Wasser
ist und da war auch diese manatory ever
creation
ja also dramatische Lage gerade dort bei
ihnen wir wünschen Ihnen natürlich alles
Gute und vor allem dass sie heil und
gesund diesen Hurricane überstehen
können Sie nachts noch schlafen kurze
Frage noch
nicht so gut ja es ging zumindest bis
heute morgen um 4 Uhr aber seitdem
Pendel ich hier von den von einer
sicheren Ecke in die andere und hoffe
dass der Wind nachlässt wir drücken die
Daumen alles Gute für Sie und bleiben
Sie gesund
danke tschüss
[Musik]